Hey guys,
In case you missed it,
we started a new series on DLM Men's Lifestyle.
This is a series where it's family-friendly
content where I just show you what's
going on in my life, being a true
reborn Christian, where I do daily things.
I share a little bit of things that I do at
work with Nikita. my awesome wife here - friends
- family - people at work - and also what I love
to do like fishing and going outdoors.
And so expect to see some great content
in this day and age we live in where
entertainment is getting darker and darker.
I want to ask you - please
join me with your family.
Watch it.
It's on Men's Lifestyle.
It's on one of the playlists called DLM Lifestyle.
We are on Episode 2 right now and this last
weekend I went out with the DLM team only
men - Danie and Jaques - we went to pray, spend
time in God's word and also do some fishing.
Check it out.
Don't miss it.
Love you guys.
Bye.